What do I mean by multiplicity? Well, we've seen with class models,
that we can adorn the associations, with stars and numbers and
so on. And this indicates, how the number of instances of one class,
is related to the number of instances in another class. For example,
we could have 1 to 1 associations, like spouses. Okay,
we could have 1-m, 1 to multiple associations, like a parent and
the parent's children. Or we could have m to n,
multiple to multiple associations, like we might have between students and
courses. That is, a student could take multiple courses, and a course could have
multiple students in it. There's the ability in UML to express each of those
possibilities by, adorning the ends of the association with numbers or stars and
so on. In UML, when multiplicity is used,
the result of navigating is some kind of collection. It might be a set.
It might be a bag, it might be a sequence. And, UML, and
OCL in particular, has a notation, that allows you to po,
perform operations on those collections. The notation is
a hyphen followed by a greater than. You can think of this as an arrow.